ciao ragazzi questo qui è un video
difficile per me è giugno e io lo
scherzo sempre dicendo che giunge il
momento nel quale di che si risvegliano
tutti quanti si ricordano di loro perché
questo è il mese del pride poi come
primo luglio possono tornare a essere
invisibili per scomparire
avevamo preparato un monologo monologo
questo momento mi sembra fuori luogo
perché in questo mese
questo mese che teoricamente più degli
altri dovrebbe essere ancora più
colorato io non vedo colori oggi non
voglio parlare di quella che è la mia
battaglia oggi vorrei essere un alleato
per una battaglia che non mi appartiene
una battaglia che non posso capire ma
una causa per la quale io devo devo
parlare perché altrimenti sarebbe
inutile per questa piattaforma
molte persone questo periodo rimangono
in silenzio in silenzio perché si si ha
paura di dire la cosa sbagliata ed è per
questo che qualora dovessi commette uno
strafalcione qualora dovessi dire una
cazzata qualora dovessi sbagliare
qualche termine o qualche concetto è per
questo che vi chiedo scusa ma
soprattutto vi chiedo di capire che
eventuali errori vengono dall ignoranza
personale e non da una cattiveria
eventuali errori vengono magari dalla
cultura che mi ha spinto e mi continua a
spingere a vedere il mondo in un certo
tipo anche se io faccio di tutto perché
non sia così ci tengo a dire questo
perché il mio invito è quello sempre di
parlare di difendere gli altri e di
combattere le battaglie che non ci
riguardano perché quando si parla di
soprusi di deboli bisogna essere in
tanti a volte esistono minoranze che
meritano giustizia ma che non hanno
abbastanza forza per potersi far valere
parlare di discriminazione razziale
non è facile per le persone che non la
subiscono c'è una sensibilità che
improvvisamente esce fuori c'è una paura
c'è anche una grandissima ipocrisia per
rendersi conto dei propri errori anche
involontari e se non sono propri di
quelli delle persone che ci circondano
jean floyd immagino che sappiate che chi
sta parlando sta parlando
americano che è stato ucciso da un
sergente di polizia
george floyd giorno va in una
tabaccheria ancora non so come si chiami
numerica per prendere un pacchetto di
sigarette dà i soldi al commesso il
commesso mi guarda e pensa che la
banconota contraffatta chiama la polizia
la polizia lo arresta ci sono immagini
di george floyd che viene scortato verso
l'auto ora se quest'uomo si sia
ribellato oppure no io non lo so quello
che soffice sono immagini terribili di
jones floyd steso a terra con il
ginocchio di uno dei poliziotti premuto
contro il collo così come vengono
utilizzati a volte cuscinetti nelle
chiese per non farsi male alle gambe
quando ci si inginocchia per pregare
così quest'uomo utilizzava il collo è
stata persona per bloccarla sicuramente
non per parlare come un dio cioè ford è
rimasto questa posizione col ginocchio
di quest'uomo piantato contro il collo
davanti ad atti tre poliziotti che non
hanno fatto nulla per 8 minuti e 46
leggo dal sito di blacklight smart punto
com il fatto che george floyd si è
rimasto così a supplicare di non essere
ucciso dicendo non riesco a respirare e
che prima di morire abbia invocato sua
madre io non riesco a immaginare il
terrore la paura e il senso di impotenza
che possa portare un uomo un adulto a
invocare insomma 8 minuto e 46 ci prova
in testualmente uno degli afroamericani
che perde la vita per un abuso di potere
da parte della polizia è solo uno degli
afroamericani che per me la vita per
colpa del razzismo
il 23 febbraio ragazzo riusciva a
correre i due uomini padre e figlio
hanno pensato che rientrasse
dell'identikit di un uomo che scappava
dove aver commesso uno scippo questi due
uomini l'hanno inseguito con la macchina
dopo aver ripreso le pistole che l'ho
caricato erano ucciso sono tanti
tantissimi gli uomini e le donne bianche
che davanti
hanno l'istinto di cambiare strada di
stringersi la borsa al petto di
avvicinare a sé i propri figli per paura
di cosa mi chiedo paura di un'idea
rispondo le notizie le storie ci vengono
raccontate sui neri intendono sempre a
esporli in maniera negativa
fa notizia quando uccidono qualcuno
quando spacciano droga fa la notizia
quando si ammazzano un l'altro e quelle
che sono le lotte del ghetto fanno
notizia per tutti i motivi che fanno
male sono molto più rari processo
alimenti aiutano stare che parlano di
educazione di emancipazione di traguardi
ed è anche per queste storie che il
pigmento della pelle ci porta a pensare
cosa si nasconda sotto l'anima non ha un
colore i muscoli il sangue le ossa
lo stesso colore per tutti e giudicare
una persona delle apparenze veramente il
massimo operato di superficialità in
questo periodo parliamo di quanto siano
importanti le vite dei neri
l'ex rais max e di come venne aggiunto
dopo un lines mazza tutte le vite sono
importante ed è interessante sto
discorso e mi porta però a pensare a una
frase che riceva un ragazzo di cui
nemmeno ricordo il nome perché sono
giorni nei quali mi informo perché
questa è l'unica cosa che posso fare in
questo momento questo ragazzo metteva
l'accento su un qualcosa di interessante
canale di diritti umani e di come mirino
venissero nemmeno considerati umani per
chi neri fino a non troppo tempo fa
erano una proprietà che le persone
acquistavano le persone scambiavano alla
stregua di un oggetto di un macchinario
per i campi io non
quante persone che non siano dei diretti
interessati possano veramente
comprendere cosa voglia dire non solo
venire da un passato simile ma subire un
presente river peto la discriminazione
che per metà ho subito subisco un
determinato tipo di discriminazione ma
non potrò mai capire cosa si prova
essere discriminati nella propria pelle
ma so che mi seguono persone che
subiscono quotidianamente
discriminazione ma oggi non siamo qui
per piangerci addosso oggi sono qui per
fare un passo indietro e riconosce il
dono degli altri leggiamo sul sito
compita punto it
una frase che è stata scritta
sull'america il peccato originale
americano e quello di essere una nazione
nata sulla brutalità del lavoro
schiavistico questo lo spiega fabrizio
tonello docente di scienze politiche a
padova un peccato che si sconta anche
centinaia di anni dopo averlo commesso
il sistema di polizia negli stati uniti
è rimasto impregnato di razzismo i corpi
sono esagerati gli internati e ancora
intesi come strumento di difesa dei
privilegi
nel momento in cui le forze dell'ordine
che giurano di proteggere i cittadini
nel momento in cui queste diventano il
nemico e diventa una minaccia e
diventano motivo di paura qualcosa non
funziona nel momento in cui le persone
possono tenere delle armi per legittima
difesa parli che possono essere
utilizzate in modo arbitrario per
uccidere innocenti
qualcosa non funziona esistono
infrazioni in america per cui
rischiereste di essere arrestato per le
quali in europa forse rischieresti una
multa
vi invito a cercare alcune di queste
online non posso non citare la storia di
un uomo nero che ha attraversato la
strada dove luciano le strisce
atteggiamento sbagliato pericoloso che
come punizione lo ha portato a essere
arrestato e malmenato dalla polizia
con questo non voglio dire che l'america
sia
con questo non voglio dire che in italia
invece si stia benissimo quello che
voglio dire è che queste cose succedono
e non è ammissibile che succedono
ora c'è una cosa che questo youtube
praticamente non si dovrebbe fare in
generale sui social che è quella di
rimanere in silenzio
abbiamo il terrore di riempire ogni
secondo delle parole questa è una cosa
che invito anche alcuni colleghi
chiunque vorrà affare che sia su questa
piattaforma o su qualsiasi altra
piattaforma poi abbiate che siete
persone con seguito infinito oppure no
sul sito black l'ice master punto com
ho letto questo invito che veniva fatto
di rimanere in silenzio per 8 minuti e
46 il tempo in cui george floyd è
rimasto per terra o un ginocchio sul
collo per gli impediva di respirare 8
minuti e 46 nei quali vorrei evitare di
riempire i silenzi che vi invito a
riempire di silenzio perché per quanto
possa essere un po marzo liana come
frase il silenzio a coltivarla 8 minuti
e 46 che vi invito a prendermi se siete
in macchina se state facendo qualsiasi
cosa c'è stata una persona che si è
presi nonostante non volesse noi
possiamo fare una scelta anche solo per
mostrare il nostro sostegno
7 il timer e vediamo quanto il nuovo
vostro silenzio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la morte di jobs avrebbe forse la goccia
che ha fatto traboccare un vaso pieno di
tante tante altre morti per quelli
queste non sono riusciti nemmeno a
comparire il trafiletto di un giornale e
la rabbia la ribellione è vero coinvolge
anche persone innocenti gestori di
locali i costi che vengono della stati
distrutti ma la rabbia
io la capisco e davanti a una rabbia
così forte e così grande
io sono il primo lo ammetto a trovarmi
in difficoltà nell'uscire a scindere la
sottile linea tra ciò che è giusto e ciò
che è sbagliato il primo pride nasce da
una serie di soprusi perpetrati dalla
polizia
i motivi stonewall riassumono una serie
di scontri tra la polizia newyorkese e
il mondo omosessuale scontri che
avvenivano all'interno di locali che lo
carica in particolare che la polizia di
padova dove avvenivano arresti percosse
maltrattare omosessuali e transessuali
che lo stanno facendo nulla di sbagliato
se non appartenere a una minoranza che
non andava bene ad alcune persone
modulati solamente da una cosa
l'odio l'omofobia la paura del diverso e
tanto più cerchi di schiacciare una vita
che tende e tenderà sempre alla libertà
tanto più prima o poi questa si
ribellerà a rappresentare l'inizio di
questa ribellione fu il gesto di una
donna transessuale sylvia rivera che non
c'è una bottiglia contro un poliziotto
un gesto sbagliato di per sé ma motivato
da una rabbia e da una frustrazione che
a volte portano a commettere gesti
sbagliati per le ragioni giuste io non
so se quello che è un gesto molto più
caro perché una morte la morte di un
uomo possa portare a un vero cambiamento
io me lo auguro ma finché questo cambio
possa avvenire dovrà per forza morire
dentro e qualcosa
il pregiudizio l'odio e l'ignoranza se
noi non saremo disposti a soffocare
questi sentimenti
allora quella di george lloyd sarà
sicuramente un'altra morte
faccio la differenza adesso spero che
questa differenza rimanga nel tempo
possa che le persone sono stanche e
anche essere più docile quando viene
messo alle strette franti tutto per
ottenere la propria libertà del proprio
diritto di essere rispettato amato e
accettato e questo è quello che auguro a
tutte quante le persone che ad oggi si
sentono schiacciate da uno stato da
persone che invece di sostenerli
rispettarli chiamarli che schiacciano
sull'asfalto che non gli permettono di
respirare